the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video all right my
friends in this video i will be
discussing what i think is a fairly
significant update regarding house of
the dragon hbo successor show to game of
thrones now as you all know hbo has been
developing a number of different shows
that are set within george rr martin's a
song of ice and fire universe and one of
those shows is house household the
dragon based on george rr martin's fire
and blood house of the dragon will be
focusing on the targaryen family as they
fight over the line of succession during
the events that are now known as the
dance of the dragons the dance of
dragons a true telling by grand mister
monken being a history of the war of
targaryen succession between the
princess frienera and aegon second of
his name that nearly destroyed the realm
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again now for those of you who
don't know hbo is already done filming
the first season of this new show during
a recent interview one of hbo's
executives casey bloys updated everyone
on the status of house of the dragon i
want to go over what he said
make sure you stick around for the end
of my video because i will be saving the
best news for last first let me show you
what he said over a deadline
the article says house of the dragon
will be releasing on hbo max later this
year but we already knew that hbo and
hbo max's content officer casey bloise
told deadline that they are currently in
talks with the team behind the dragons
to figure out exactly when to launch
this spin-off fantasy series and he
admits that the network was cautious
about revealing a date because of
everything happening with all of the
lockdowns the new series which comes
from george rr martin ryan condole and
miguel sapochnick has now finished
production and fans should expect an
update soon
now casey went on to say one of the
reasons why we're trying to be cautious
about it is when you're shooting a show
that big during a pandemic especially
with the last round with a lot of the
crew and cast members you don't know who
is going to drop out or if we're going
to have to shut down so we didn't want
to declare a date then find ourselves
shut down he said now that we are out of
production i think that we will discuss
this with our guys and figure out what
we want to do in regards of announcing a
date but i was just trying to make sure
that we didn't come out with a date that
we couldn't meet for something that was
out of our control casey also spoke
about the other successor shows that are
in various stages of development
deadline revealed last march that the
network was developing three different
ideas for new shows set within george rr
martin's fantasy world including 9
voyages aka the sea snake flea bottom
and 10 000 ships
steve conrad is also attached to write a
duncan egg series
casey blois said that there was nothing
to really report there but admitted that
some of them are beginning to look
really good it's just like any
development process
some are looking really good some will
see we're not gonna try to make
everything i don't have any mandate that
i must make a certain amount of game of
thrones successor shows or anything like
that we're really doing it just based on
what we're excited about creatively so
as you can see he doesn't really give us
any updates right here but he does say
something very interesting in his
following interview let me show you what
he said when he sat down at variety
during this interview casey said he
wasn't ready to announce when the series
might release or even hint at what time
of the year it might finally arrive just
yet
but yes the network is already thinking
about a renewal if you're better on
whether we're gonna do a second season i
think it's a good bet he said
but obviously we'll make preparations
ahead of time to make sure we're ahead
of the game he remains quiet on the
status of the other game of thrones
shows and development repeating his line
that right now there's one game of
thrones show that is green lit and that
is house of the dragon which we're
excited by i feel really good about what
i've seen so far as for any more green
light announcements i would never
announce it around the launch of a new
show whether to greenlight something or
not those are separate events alright
now since he didn't give very many
updates during his interview i want to
focus on what he said at the very end
because i think it's a very exciting
revelation as you can see he said he's
very excited about house of the dragon
and he feels really good about what he
has seen so far in fact he feels so good
about it he's already expecting the show
will be given a second season which is
very interesting if you ask me the way
hbo has been handling house of the
dragon is very different from how
they've handled many other shows
first of all they gave house of the
dragon a full series order without even
seeing a pilot episode which almost
never happens usually what a network
will do is order a pilot episode so they
can see if it's even good enough to
order a full season they did this with
game of thrones and basically every
other show they've ever made however for
some reason they did not do this with
house of the dragon
so without even seeing a single episode
not only did they order a full season
but now they're even expecting this new
series to be given a second season at
the very least everything must have gone
extremely well during the developmental
phase of house of the dragon otherwise
i'm not sure why they would be this
confident
especially when you consider they
already lost 30 million dollars on the
series about the long night they must
really like what they've seen so far and
they must have a lot of faith in ryan
condo and miguel sapochnick which is
obviously a good thing because the show
is now in their hands unfortunately it
doesn't sound like we will see house of
the dragon during the front half of the
year as you all know i was hoping it
would release in april like most game of
thrones seasons did but now i'm thinking
we won't see it until the summer or
maybe even later as of right now nothing
is confirmed by hbo so for all i know we
could see the first episode on any given
day this year i guess we will all just
have to wait and see as always i will
keep you updated on any information i
see whether it's about game of thrones
house of the dragon or anything relating
to a song of ice and fire if you want to
see those videos as soon as i release
them make sure you subscribe now so you
will know whenever a new video is out
for now i want to thank all of you for
watching this video hopefully i will see
you back here for my next one have a
great day everyone i will see you soon
bye
the dance began as many dancers do with
an old man and a young girl the queen
had failed to produce a son for her king
so he anointed his daughter the princess
rhaenyra as his heir but years later the
king remarried and his new wife queen
alicent of house hightower gave him a
son
feeble and foolish the old king refused
to change the succession he didn't even
see how his court had split into two
rival camps of blacks and greens after
the dresses of the princess and the
queen had worn to some torny
so
[Music]
so
you